mouse to go and rest - and welcome to a
new pixelated horror game it's called
lights and shades here we go
this game is a [ __ ] nightmare man I
lost the gameplay on my first try of
this game but to give you an idea it
looks something like this and of course
your night you haven't been wearing
pants on a week maybe it's time to shave
those legs I don't know I'll just say
okay I'm sorry
let's go you have sexy legs by god this
[ __ ] jump scares I'm gonna [ __ ]
die of one if I die from a jump scare
put on my gravestone died from being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] now oh god that [ __ ]
why do you see other food so quick man
oh I got a good look on him man he's
really handsome man so I dropped the
bottles and then he likes them I don't
know how it works and it's gonna keep
running that's the tactic err okay we
can do this it's just a [ __ ] game is
this I'm scared of him jumping in my
face don't to make that sound but Opower
oh god where we going I'm just gonna
keep pouring forward Ron Ron Ron pills
run here
this is like ghouls forests all over
again
holy-moly boldly poliana Broly i don't
want to attract the attention I should
probably not use my light so too much I
never use it except those few times but
I want to see where I'm going okay okay
we're going they don't use the light
source don't use lights us and it'll all
be fine
the Liberals watch that show moomintroll
it with that thing in the woods it looks
identical and I hated that thing that
thing scared me so much when I was a
child if if there's more cameras around
I better find them all why I don't even
know what are we going mama I shut up
these mist bottles are the only thing
that seems to keep stable things away oh
really but I can't see where the [ __ ] he
is when he comes all right
go straight here okay keep going
I made it so far the first time it's so
dark I I don't see anything either Bros
so don't complain I like I shaft I echo
- muah
just came bottles why did I drop all of
them you idiot Puetz what okay okay
don't have anybody else and I'm out of
my flash huh okay we can do this we can
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] man ain't no
[ __ ] thing's gonna kill me
we're too bad as for us we're just too
badass this game is easy man this game
is for [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] big on
spawn of Satan shut up shut up myself
I need babies nerd shut up shut up
geez man sheesh Matilda grab it you dick
sucking [ __ ] mocking there you are
okay it's all good in the hood and
inside the head is a med and outside the
head as a pledge and I just want to
shake my booty all night long check that
pony I have do tall topless come talk to
us come on then
don't flash that we took the follow
everyone did by the way pushes your my
only friends okay so far everything is
really nice very really nice okay better
not use my flashlight Oh mm-hmm just
want to make sure something down there
isn't it yep let's just keep going
straight this scares sucking terrifying
you don't even have anything why do they
like bottle so much am I going backwards
oh god that [ __ ] sound oh god oh god
take the bottle man I have no quarter
with you just take the bottle [ __ ]
minecraft in the ass man [ __ ] mine
crab man Oh milky oh thank god more milk
man if I knew they wanted milk I just
let him suck on my titties man what he's
pissed take the milk and we'll I'll be
on my way sir take the milk and now
we'll all be it'll be fine
we'll forget this ever happened I didn't
take the milk all right I don't know it
doesn't sound like he didn't take the
milk
it's crazy how you can get scared by a
bunch of [ __ ] pixels main I'm gonna
find that house I'm gonna find that
[ __ ] house man need my key fob all
that I have Tommy again God's milk
[ __ ]
okay there's a house I'm sure that will
be less creepy oh god what what dole I
should probably not harm this doll if I
want to attract anything evil just stay
away please hello oh god oh god
who's crying stop crying that'd be all
milk thank God milk it's they're
upstairs er what am i I have so many
dolls
don't touch me I have a doll I have a
[ __ ] doll don't touch me don't touch
me I have a doll oh and milk oh nice
nice I like to finger paint oh man we
have something in common that's great we
could be friends oh I like it I like
what you did done with the Oh God [ __ ]
that [ __ ] [ __ ] man do you want this
doll I have plenty main pick up them you
cannot set the doll on fire with a
flashlight the book creates our children
oh hey that's that's a really nice face
you got there okay set the doll on fire
man just set the doll on fire man oh god
oh god oh god yeah you like this [ __ ] I
must set your [ __ ] on fire girl if you
don't play nice the doll burns yay yay
where the [ __ ] did he go set the doll on
fire man set the doll on fire where the
[ __ ] did he go oh this is so this game
is [ __ ] terrifying
okay our children now of six leads shall
never enter circle of sight for us they
will smite I will [ __ ] smite your ass
that's what I'm [ __ ] do I will burn
him I will burn him I will burn your
little Jimmy if it's the last thing I'll
do Jimmy will burn man all right let's
find a fireplace or some [ __ ] like that
oh how do you have blood on that caught
some mini hell better thank the milk
piece of [ __ ]
Oh shadow shadow shadow change what do
you come from okay we're fine you wear
your tough enemy I can't even trust the
message yet no no